well mike matthew gentlemen
congratulations you're going into the
third and final round where you'll be
battling it out from your home forges
fighting for that title of fortune fire
champion and a check for ten thousand
dollars now guys in this final round you
will be building an iconic weapon from
history
and that weapon is this
matched set of curved guitars
while the qatar was immensely popular in
india during the 16th and 17th century
this curved version is extremely rare
and has been hailed as one of the most
unique weapons in history the arneat
handle construction features two bars
for the grip and provides the user
enough control to make a very effective
fighting knife as a pair the curved
guitars were designed to deliver quick
and lethal stabs and slashes using both
arms today this one-of-a-kind weapon can
be seen on display at the metropolitan
museum of art in new york
do your very best work we will see you
in four days
my name is matthew shirey i live in the
smoky mountains of north carolina
and i think i'm ready to win i've got a
wife and two little boys we like to
spend a lot of time in the outdoors
together i think i can be pretty funny
sometimes i make my kids laugh anyway i
don't know about other people
i'll put the piece of steel in between
those two
dies and and forge the fuller
this is the part i was most nervous
about so i'm gonna take it nice and slow
[Music]
finally got my fullers roughed in these
are the crossbars for the handle
challenges are gonna be getting these
handles just right so i've just done
what's called a reverse twist there i've
got the frames fabricated for my my
blades and the crossbars and it's time
to start assembling them
my handle in round two wasn't quite
perfect and uh i want to make sure that
doesn't happen in the final round
got the handles attached to the blades
and uh ready for heat treat there's
always a moment of truth i'm a little
nervous going into it
yep that one looks good getting number
two and we're good to go
[Music]
good and hard i feel ecstatic about my
progress i'm really pleased with the way
they're looking
mike demosky i'm a knife maker from west
point nebraska i'm a stay-at-home dad
and i make knives in my free time
room before we back home is my family
they mean the world to me and they would
love if i brought this money back to him
i want to get this going right now yeah
for sure
am i cussing too much i'm thinking this
one steel construction
you know might
put me over the top
i'm stoked about how it's looking right
now i need to be comfortable in their
hands that means that it's better to go
wider so i want to make sure that
they're not digging into their arms
they're looking good
i'm having a little bit of an issue
getting these two sides of the brackets
lined up perfectly looks like
i don't know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
have to figure this out quick though
there's not not a lot of time left
i think before i start making another
one i might try to forge weld that back
on there
if i get this back on there it'd be a
miracle
ah
done so i got this broken blade i'm
gonna need to try to salvage this i'm
gonna try to weld the bracket back
together it's gonna be interesting this
welder does not work i'm probably not
gonna be able to have a second blade to
turn in here i go
let's see if it holds
i'm going to throw it a few times and
see what happens
if it's going to fail i want it to fail
here in my hands not when the judges are
using it
i mean i feel good about that
let's get these handles on here
so at the end of day four finally got
these finished and sharpened i am super
stoked right now
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
dynamic heel test
mike you're first you ready i'm ready
all right mike let's talk about your
curved guitars here for a match set not
bad they're almost identical in the feel
of your weapon your edges are sharp and
overall sir
you'll kill it's great to hear
matthew your turn are you ready yes sir
let's have fun
all right matthew let's talk about your
curve guitars here first up i like the
scale of your blades because guitars are
the well the big daddies of push daggers
and push decks are relatively small so
there's a scale that goes with it to
make it easier to control and i think
you've got that with your blades but
that way gives also a nice support when
i'm stabbing and slashing overall sir
your curved guitars you will keel thank
you
all right gentlemen welcome to our
dynamic strength test the kendo stick
chop and ballistic tube slice
mike you're up first you ready yep let's
do it okay
all right mike right off it's an
interesting way to build these it's a
non-traditional way but um the issue i
have is that there's so much space
around my hands
that
they kind of
are trying to find what's comfortable
the other thing that uh noticed is your
blade
is really no longer in line
with the handle
but good cutters they held up nice and
done thanks dave
matthew you ready let's do it okay
so
so matthew wright off good traditional
look to these i like that a lot they cut
like they're supposed to cut they're
plenty strong they held their edge
beautifully good job thank you
[Music]
placements there is nothing easy about
fighting this forge and the two of you
proved yourself in the final round with
some unique blades now unfortunately
only one of you go home today with the
win today's fortune fire champion is
[Music]
matthew congratulations man mike you
fought hard you're talented smith but
unfortunately you're not taking home the
win today i'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the fourth floor
thank you sir good fight mike pretty
bummed right now a lot of highs and a
lot of lows and here we are matthew that
makes you today's fortune fire champion
you just got yourself a check for ten
thousand dollars congratulations
how you feeling
fantastic i feel elated been a hard
challenge from the first round to the
last
i'm just on cloud nine right now
you